after a very long and very cold covered
christmas break calgary schools are back
in session i'm excited about it like and
especially for my son because you know
he's missing a lot of the socialization
aspect of it all they want to see their
friends
they haven't seen them for
quite a few weeks now but the return of
in-person learning across bc and alberta
comes as omicron cases continue to rise
and school-aged children are nowhere
near immune approximately 25 to 35
children per day are testing positive at
the alberta children's hospital right
now
and that's a dramatic spike from where
we were with any of the other waves
where the peak was generally around four
to five children per day dr stephen
friedman does not believe schools should
move to remote learning but he does
worry about the variance rapids spread
i'm glad they are back in school now um
and they are doing in-person learning
but i think that that should be a last
resort and we really do need to restrict
other
places venues and
where individuals are contracting
omicron otherwise schools may not be
able to stay open for long by noon
monday with a shortage of more than 300
staff the calgary board of education
moved five classes online something
canadian families east of saskatchewan
were having to deal with already it's
very hard for the kids to follow and
engage with especially when they're
special ed students right with four kids
on the autism spectrum suzel munez is
hopeful ontario kids will return to
in-person learning next week as planned
in toronto the emphasis is on vaccines
that booster effort is continuing
non-stop in the face of the omicron
variant along with our push to get kids
vaccinated and to help education and
child care workers to get vaccinated so
that the province and school boards can
get back to in-person learning on
january the 17th there is widespread
consensus across medical professionals
that for the social and emotional health
and well-being of kids getting and
keeping schools open should be priority
number one especially as we begin this
third year under covet 19. heather urex
west global news calgary